Với năng cấp nhận nước kéo sai muốn ngày của tổng bị thư chủ tịch lất tổ lâm và phù nhân kết thúc này mẹ bài tháng tư.
Tết tục nhận được sự quan tâm của giới chuyên gia và chuyên thông Trung Quốc,
với nhiều đánh giá cho rằng, thấy là bước đi mạnh ý nghĩa chính là trong gia đoạn mới của khoản hệ 2 nước.
Sao đổi, phải bao chi sẽ vắc kênh, chuyên gia nghiên cứu Việt Nam,
trường bán tính việc của đã phát tháng và chuyênh những trong ở Trung Quốc quyết vi nhận định.
Sao khi được bao làm chủ tịch nước Việt Nam, với tổ lâm của lần nữa,
cho chúng Quốc là đi đến nước ngoài đường tiền.
Đây đủ sĩ có trọng của ông, đối với vực phát triển quan hệ chủ Việt.
Vì chính của chuyên thông viện ra giây đặc, và đại nhiều khi qua tu đẹp.
Một trường bộ công phố phóng quan trẻ chủ đời chiến năng.
Một trường giấu ấn nội bật trước hết là việc tiếp tục cùng có tin cạnh chính trị,
cấp cao nhất, các cuộc tiếp xúc giây đặc dưới lãnh đạo 2 đàn,
2 nhận nước tiếp tục khẳng định và trọng giận giác của cấp cao trong điểm hướng tổng thể quan hệ xong vân.
Đáng chuyến, một tiêu trong tuyên bộ Trung gá được năng lên thành xây dược
có đồng chi sẽ tương lai Việt Nam Trung Quốc, coi nghĩa chính lực ở bước độ cao hơn,
và nánh mức độ hành kết ngày càng xấu giác.
Ở cóc độ hợp tác thực chất, hạ tăng đặc biệt là đường xác,
nội lên như một diệm nhận trong chuyến thông,
tổng viết thư chủ tịch nước tổ lâm đã chực tiếp trả nghiệm tầu cao tốt trên nhiều trạng giải.
Trong đó có hành trình hơn hành in 1 trạng kí lo mát từ mắc tình đến năm nay.
Yếu thăm khu mới hùng ăn, hệ giận gió sự quan tâm của Việt Nam,
lửa tinh nhận phát triển và xây dược lâu khi nào cho chúng quốc.
Tụ quốc và Việt Nam cũng chung nè thông dính chi,
và đều đã chứ có đường xây dừng quốc gia sạo của chúng biếp của giới mình.
Tụi mấy, khi nhận phát triển của chúng quốc là phù hợp với Việt Nam,
cũng thì sẽ thông ăn của đồng chỉ tổ lâm.
Mà để gã nhìn chức quan về cách chúng quốc tích hợp các công nghệ thông mình,
xanh và đều mới, mà con bộ ở trên việc hành.
Xây dược và phát triển đủ thi của các những bà họt quan trọng cho sự phát triển đủ thi của Việt Nam.
Tụi mấy thúc tốt lâm trạng nhận, tạo có tốt và tinh hiểu công nghệ và tàn.
Cho thấy Việt Nam rất quan tâm bió phát triển đủ sát hiện lại.
Bệt là giữ ăn lửa sất cậu tốt và nào.
Không chỉ giữa lại ở trạng giọc.
Đây còn là thông được chính sách về định giữang phát triển hạ tăng kết nối trong thời gian tối.
Các phần kèn kí kết cũng cho thấy nhớ bức tiến của thè từ thúc đời giữa ăn đường sát lòng cai hà nội hải phòng.
Đến hợp tác chuyổi cùng ngấn nân cấp cửa khẩu và kẻ lột tích.
Các tiếp cận cũng có sự chuyển dịch só dễ.
Tự các sự ăn diên lẻ sẵn lên kết theo chuối, xuất tăng hiệu quả và giảm chí vị trong vật động thương mại xong phương.
Bình kẹn đó, hợp tác trong các lượng vực mới giữa kho học công nghệ lỗi mời sáng tạo chỉ tựa nhìn tạo.
Cũng đăng mở ra dưu điện phát triển mời, phù hợp với su hướng nân cao chết lợp tăng trường của khả hải nước.
Một điểm nhấn khác là việc tăng cường nên tàng sá hội của quả khẩu sông tương.
Các hoạt động dàu liệu thách nhiên tư biểu như chứng chình hành trình đò,
đang có phần cùng có sự gánh kết dữa thế hệ trẻ hải nước.
Có thể thấy tự nhiễm định hướng chế lợp được sắc lập ở cấp cao đến hệ thống các thỏa thuật hợp tác cuu thế,
có lụi trình trình thái só sàng. Cô thể Việt Nam Trung Quốc nặng bước vào một xe đoạn phát triển mời thực chất và hiệu quả hơn.
Chênh nên tàng tinh gạy chính trị được cùng bố ở hợp tác này cảnh đi vào chỗ sâu,
những căng kết đặt được trong chuyến thăm lần này của tổn viết thư chủ tích nước tổn lâm,
được kì vào sẽ sớm được dựa thật quả, mạng lại lợp ít thức trong người dân dựa phái nước.
Đồng thời có phần cùng có mua trường hoa mình, ổn đánh và phát triển trong cú vực.